Standing here with Effie
and Ze'ev.
Yes.
We are here on the Golan Heights,
and we are looking into Syria,
sight of just the worst civil war imaginable.
Syrians, who are wounded
or in need of medical attention,
have been getting medical attention from the Israelis.
Sometimes they are wounded
and sometimes those are sick women or children.
I cannot imagine how they feel.
You know sometimes they come
and they're just so scared,
and you can barely get them talk.
And sometimes they say, "Toda,"
"Thank you" in Hebrew that's,
in my language.
For a Syrian to thank you
in Hebrew is pretty special.
Yes.
You can hear?
That's the civil war.
What we're hearing right now--
Right now is exchange of fire
between the regime and the rebels.
That's the city of Nakonechna.
That city is controlled by the regime.
Okay? By Assad's military.
And the village right here is controlled by rebels.
That's machine gun fire we hear,
rifle fire--
Machine guns,
heavy machine guns.
[Conan] Heavy machine guns.
(bellowing gunfire)
Now, this is going on all the time.
Uh, this is relatively calm, okay?
Relatively calm, relative to war.
That's mind-numbing that
that's relatively calm.
That's relatively calm.
Yeah, I've never heard an actual war before.
That's pretty sobering.
Syrians are treated near the border,
and then they're taken here.
Standing here with Dr. Roisentul and with Fares.
Dr. Roisentul, obviously you treat
the Syrians that come here and need help.
And, Fares, you are a social worker.
You speak Arabic and you say that's important
because when the Syrians come in they're very afraid,
so if someone can speak Arabic to them,
it calms them, is that right?
Yes.
You're treating Syrians here who've been injured
in the civil war.
You don't treat them just medically,
they're also treated psychologically, is that true?
Yeah, that true,
because some people they have illnesses.
They also come here because they have a trauma.
[Conan] Right.
They have a trauma from the war.
They have a trauma from leaving the country.
I think you're doing God's work here.
I honestly, sincerely think you're doing
beautiful work here.
The only thing I question about you
are these medical Crocs.
(crowd laughing)
That, I think,
is the only thing that separates you
from a godlike status.
(crowd laughing)
We are only human.
[Conan] Yeah, we all have our mistakes.
You bought those.
(crowd laughing)
You saw them at the mall and you had to have them.
Other than the Crocs,
I think you should get the Peace Prize,
I really do.
(clapping)
Next I visited
with some of the Syrian patients,
whose faces we had to blur
for their own protection.
(speaking in foreign language)
Please tell him that I'm very sorry
for his injury and his pain.
And, coming here and seeing everyone here
who's been injured and meeting them,
it's very powerful for me.
The world is very aware of the horrors in Syria.
And, we're hoping that together,
maybe we can find a solution so that this can stop.